it will be game number one in the
history of globe life field there are no
fans of course here but the doppel
rangers are now in place
2700 cardboard cutouts big number 35
working in the short sleeves showing
just about an inch of blue t-shirt and
sleeve underneath the rangers a new
white home jersey with rangers in the
blue logo script outlined in white and
red across the front potential
first run of the game just 90 feet away
now with nolan arenado very dangerous
hitter at the right side swung on popped
up behind the plate torinos appears to
have a play and he does
on the warning track lin gets out of the
innings strands are under it third the
rockies did not put a ball in play last
year herman 28 starts
every night you felt like hey with his
stuff if the if the planet's alive he
could throw a no hitter andrews
setting a rangers record as he's the
first rangers player in the franchise's
history to start 12 consecutive opening
days
that is a dirty slider and andrus waves
at it first strike out of the night for
marquez two god nobody on marquez kicks
and fires and he struck him out swinging
took something off there and it's a one
two three inning for herman marquez
runners at first and second for nolan
aronados
swing and a pop-up this is out near
second rookie in charge goes a ways
towards first makes the one hand grab to
get aronado for the final out so no runs
a hit the rockies leave two so the first
base runner comes
at the bottom of the order and that
breaks the string of eight straight
retired to begin the game and here's
shinsu the leadoff man and the
designated hitter breaking ball caught
strike three and chew was caught napping
airman marquez has given up one walk
through three innings that is it no fans
in the stands but there was one
exception made and it wasn't for a
rangers family it was for the family of
a colorado rocky a local boy named sam
hilliard who is starting tonight in left
field his first opening day start and
his family is here to watch it his
father jim is battling als and the two
front offices from the rockies and the
rangers got together figured out a way
for jim and tamra his wife and also
sam's fiance cat to be here to watch him
fastball swung on and lifted down the
left field line hilliard moving back
onto the track and he reaches up and a
little leap holds it in right at the
barrier for the second out boy that kept
carrying and hilliard stayed with it
and here's joey gallo pitch is swung on
hit up the middle behind second bobbled
by story and he's unable to make a play
and gallow will reach and trevor had to
reach down a little bit and just
couldn't bring it in they ended up
ruling that play an error on trevor's
story second straight walk served up by
airmon and that loads the bases with two
outs and chirinos is next 0-1 pitch a
weak ground ball out to mcmahon at
second he handles it throws to first and
marquez
works out of it strands the bases loaded
four complete three walks two of those
last inning and four strikeouts is not
allowed to hit he hits this one up the
middle backhanded behind the bag by
mcmahon longford a good stretch by
daniel murphy and they get kiner falefa
good play on both ends very nicely done
in particular by daniel murphy at first
two outs here in the texas fifth swing
and a miss on an off-speed pitch by
airmon marcus a one two three fifth his
fifth strikeout three guys with nine
strikeouts in opening day starts for the
rangers nolan ryan yes did it in 1991
the other two happened in 2013 and 2012.
and he did it his ninth strike out of
the ball game lance lynn
gets mcmahon for a third time tonight
rangers in pursuit of their first hit in
their new ball park this is deep short
andrus can run
out at first base
murphy stayed on the back it looked like
perhaps murphy got pulled off the bag
but at first base jim wolfe said he got
the ball before the foot came off the
bag that brings up santana in this
scoreless game he has struck out and
flied out to the left swung on hit in
the air left field moving back toward
the alley hilliard it's over his head
it's off the wall santana into second
base with a double he is the proud owner
of the first rangers hit
at globe life field two outs for
odor who has grounded to the pitcher and
walked the door
toward the alley right center it's down
basically
santana scores oh door pedals for second
and the rangers score the first run of
the ball game one nothing in the sixth
inning solid summer camping to see it
turn into a really big at-bat high
fastball look at him go up and get it
in marquez's night huge spot solid
second arnado at first a one-nothing
game and he struck him out swinging
pulled a string on him down goes murphy
and the rockies leave two men on base
matt kemp trying to
keep the rockies alive in this season
opener swinging a pop-up should end it
near first base
frazier is there ball game over
rangers christened their new ballpark
with a shutout of the colorado rockies
and a tiny one-nothing win